kamala harris once again proving to be
the world's worst boss staffers
desperately fleeing as her vice
presidency turns into a sinking ship yet
another top aide is bolting after a week
of flops cringe-worthy comments and all
around bad news kamala's chief of staff
will be the 13th and most senior aide to
get out after reports of a toxic and
abusive workplace
and the most important job she was put
in charge of the border is another
disaster even democrats can't figure out
what exactly kamala is doing about it
the democratic voters
are not happy and if you look at the
independent voters they're not happy
about this decision so who are we trying
to please
democrats are now divided thanks to the
administration border failures the party
split over biden's decision to end title
42
and it gets worse
a texas national guard soldier has died
after going on a mission to rescue
migrants
and that on a sad note
but but let's let's talk about kamala i
mean
this woman actually thinks that she can
run uh for president uh and she
apparently
is an individual who is involved in a
toxic workplace abusive environment she
doesn't read the reports and and yet she
still is in there thinking she's doing a
great job
katie what do you think of that
well i think it's obvious what her
situation is she's living in an
entitlement state because she's been
handed a number of things as a result of
just asking for them
she hasn't been vetted by she was
embedded by the california press she
certainly was invited by the national
press when she was picked for vice
president and i think on the border
issue she's been given that issue
because the administration doesn't want
to do anything about the border they
hand her a portfolio full of items that
they have an agenda on they say they're
doing something by appointing her to be
in charge of it and then they don't
actually do anything and i i want to
talk about the texas army national guard
soldier who has gone missing uh this
administration has vilified anybody from
border patrol to texas national guard to
dps in texas saying that they are racist
that they have somehow have a nefarious
agenda when it comes to the job they're
doing to defend the country this is the
kind of work that they're doing every
day going in the river taking off their
body armor to see if they can save
people who are not americans who are
entering the country illegally who are
breaking our laws and literally putting
their lines on lives on the line every
single day and there's no statement from
the white house there's no concern about
the safety and that for these people
that the administration that they put
them in this position because they
refuse to close the border and they're
still doing nothing and on title 42
there's now this convenient democratic
argument to not to end it but it really
just is a talking point because title 42
essentially has been ended they're
releasing single adult males into the
country all over the place and the
administration is not going to do
anything to change that what about what
about the fact greg that
you have someone who has died
working at the border the national guard
an american trying to save an illegal
coming to these coming to this country
in an illegal way
um
you know the the frightening part of it
all is that we haven't heard from kamala
harris i mean she is supposed to be in
charge of the border and there's no word
from the white house i mean it's almost
as though it doesn't matter what
happened she really is the cnn plus of
political leaders
i will say once a serious thing about
that
joe biden singled out a border patrol
agent accusing him of whipping haitian
immigrants they had the investigation
they found nothing they never apologized
he never apologized to the the to the
border patrol agent why doesn't he
single out this heroism it's almost like
he only singles out american citizens to
smear them right because you have these
examples where he only goes after you
know whether they're trump supporters or
you know parents at
uh at school meetings or this so that's
that's the serious thing it would be
nice if they did say something but
kamala i wonder does she ever notice
that everyone is leaving like i that
would bother me like imagine entering a
room
at a party and within 10 minutes
everyone's gone and you realize maybe
you might have stepped in some dog poop
but i mean does she is it affecting her
at all i mean does she have like does
she have somebody who's just constantly
on linkedin like trying to get people to
go do they tell her kamala i will say
this if i was an unemployed democrat i
would definitely take a job with her
because it's like voluntary volunteering
for a war it's like you know you're at a
bar and somebody says you know i was in
iraq and another guy i was in
afghanistan and you go yeah tour with
kamala uh you become a veteran of the
kamala occupation and then all of a
sudden you realize there might be a
whole group of former staffers like a
special kind of aaa that shares their
ptsd memories working with her because
there's like 13 now that's a like a
football team plus two i think right
yeah 13. thank you very much
well you know what even mayorkas is
talking about uh the fact that you know
this thing we don't we can't cover the
border if he if he drops the mandate on
may 23rd which in effect it may already
have been dropped but the truth is
you've got so many within the democrat
party you've got so many people who are
saying even mayorkas is saying it now
what is biden's option right now
well a lot of things here let me first
say these are
this this um officer at the borders
presumed that i know we hope that is not
the case that the facts don't look uh
don't look good now my prayers are with
him and his family and i would imagine
the white house will make some sort of
statement uh in due time if not before
the show's over
two
i think the president
this policy at the border has to come
from the white house
uh kamala harris has been put in charge
of this effort and we're hopeful that
she's able to articulate a policy my
frustration has been
simply what has been talked about at the
table and i think a lot of americans are
curious
what are we doing at the border
and what are we doing i think more more
holistically to try to prevent people
from coming to the border now there's a
i think a legitimate argument has been
made that some of the posturing on the
part of this administration has made it
likely that more people would come to
the border illegally
we can debate that but i think there's
probably more credence than that than
not
but i think republicans who want an
answer to this and not just the
political side of it or political issues
are democrats who politicize it too
we have to be serious about investing in
this region in this hemisphere this is
our own hemisphere we've spent trillions
over the last 25 years when you were in
congress i predated you in congress
stabilizing other parts of the world
which we should but we we spend pennies
trying to stabilize our own hemisphere
and we have to get serious about that if
we are indeed serious about controlling
and limiting the number of people who
come to the border i hope kamala gets
out the vice president gets a policy
from the president and i hope she's then
able to implement it in a serious and
firm way but harold well it's not it's
not just our hemisphere people are
coming in from all over the world right
now because the border is open and again
i think if you uh focus more on securing
your border as opposed to you know
investing money in the in the uh central
triangle uh we're going to be better off
and i think if you can do both if you
take all the talent out of these
countries who's loved to actually
rebuild the countries and have an
economy can i just talk about kamala
harris so we both have congressional
officers i'll answer the question but
you go right now
thank you i appreciate that
and you can i got a phone call
so
listen in in a congressional office we
all held and i saw this when you have
bad bosses people who are mean they yell
at their staff or people who are
ineffective you see the staff flood out
of those offices and it's a revolving
door and i'm not going to mention who
they are but you and i both know those
offices
of horrible bosses
but also you see the people want to
staff wants to consolidate around power
whether it's a leadership or ranking
member or chairman the vice president is
a really powerful position and the staff
has the more power that their boss has
and so you see people leaving kamala
harris's office as the vice president
that underscores how really bad it is
and i think people don't want to have
their reputation solid they see how bad
she is in the stump how she can't put
sentences and paragraphs together how
everything she's been delivered uh as a
as a policy priority she can't get done
they're like listen my career is too too
important to me i'm gonna step back i
don't i don't want any kamala harris on
me don't put that taint on me
you know here's
she she doesn't care anymore for her
staff than she does for the people of
the country in terms of the way she's
handling the border but that wasn't fair
president trump had a couple of national
security advisers and a few chiefs of
staff this happens these are tough
jobs and if you don't want to serve no
no but if but these are well i think if
you go back and look at the number judge
i think you'd be you'd be surprised i i
was looking at the numbers why are you
nodding it's not interesting
there was a there was a lot of turnover
in the trump administration but the
president made the decision that they
weren't doing what he wanted but the
point is it was a different reason for
turnover than this it didn't have to do
with trump it had to do with the
onslaught of the media coverage and just
the constant harassment from the outside
the staff members that the president has
compared to the small office of the vice
president if you look at percentages
she's lost a huge percentage of her
staff compared to trump
there's no comparison she lost 13 people
walked out on her hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else